It’s clear that a great many of us eat too
much. And in response, a huge industry has
grown up which advises us to consume more
quinoa, pomegranate and fennel salad and,
as often as we can, kale and apple soup. But
this is entirely to misunderstand why we start
eating excessive amounts. It has nothing to
do food, and therefore trying to change our
diet isn’t the most logical place to focus
our efforts. We eat too much because what
we’re really hungry for isn’t available.
Of course, it looks as if everything we could
want should be to hand. Our supermarkets and
delis are iconic temples of consumer society.
Our restaurants spare no effort trying to
satisfy us.
Could sir or madam be tempted by lobster thermidor?
Or a selection of regional vegetables drizzled
with olive oil sourced from a tiny farm in
the Pyrenees? But if we could really choose
anything, wouldn’t we want a slightly different
menu? For example: Unstressed conversation
of father, marinaded in mutual forgiveness.
Tenderised maternal love* (* suitable for
those on a criticism-free diet).
Ripe friendship served on wry banter accompanied
by a side serving of affectionate teasing.
Fresh conversation, liberally sprinkled with
poignant anecdotes (for two). Sexual appreciation
with all the trimmings (our sommelier recommends,
as the ideal accompaniment, a glass of full-bodied
Chateau Fantaisie). And for dessert, perhaps
A generous scoop of honeyed insight.
In other words, it isn’t food we crave.
The menus of our actual restaurants (however
chic) prompt us only in very limited and restricted
directions. They understand – and respond
– to only a desperately narrow segment of
our true appetites. Collectively, we speak
so much of food, and so little of what we
properly need. It isn’t pizza, Spanish cheese
or Argentinian steak. We need friendship where
we can confess our darkest anxieties and be
heard and forgiven; we need help in calming
down at key moments, reassured that we can
withstand the very worst that may be coming
our way. We are lonely and angry within our
own families and are crying out for redemption
and cathartic honesty. We need someone who
can help us discover our real talents in the
workplace and offer us a guide to realise
our true potential. We know that, when reaching for a tube of
potato chips or biting into yet another burrito
that the problem doesn’t lie there. We just
don’t know where else to turn and there
is, at least, a short-term satisfaction to
be found. We eat too much because we hate
ourselves too intensely to have the necessary
respect for our own bodies. Our tragedy isn’t
our unconstrained appetite. But rather, the
difficulty we have in getting access to the
emotional and psychological things that would
nourish our broken souls. The diet industry
has latched onto the symptoms of our unhappiness,
not their causes – and therefore the solutions
it offers can only ever be temporary and fragile.
It can’t make us lastingly thin because
it is not engaging with what made us manically
fat. A couple of hundred years ago it was
almost impossible for most people to find
anything very pleasant to eat. Since then,
a vast quantity of human ingenuity has been
devoted to enticing the palate. We have succeeded
beyond our wildest expectations. But in so
many other areas, we have hardly begun to
supply ourselves reliably with what we long
to consume, which are, to put it plainly:
understanding, tenderness, forgiveness, reconciliation
and closeness. We eat too much not because
we are (as we brutally accuse ourselves) greedy,
but because we live in a world where the shelves
are still bare of the real ingredients we crave.
At The School Of Life we believe in developing emotional intelligence.  To that end we have
also created a whole range of products to support that growth.
Find out more at the link on your screen now.